so my friend uh Stevo was a big
um not to Steve Stevo from Jackson you
can't just drop a Stevo right there
Korean friend of mine and he was a big
Sushi guy and I wanted to get into Sushi
I liked it and so he said the best place
is this place by his house in Studio
City and so he said he goes don't get
freaked out people just it's not going
to be a lot of people in there he said
but the people who are in there they
know and George Clooney will be there
probably I might get out of here so I
walk in it's Friday night at eight
o'clock I walk in and my friend is
sitting at the sushi bar he's the only
one there's no one else in there eight
o'clock on a Friday I'm like this place
can't be good so I sit down and there's
five people at a tent the only other
people are five people in this table and
one of them's George Clooney that's
crazy get out of here so then uh we eat
and then so I go to the bathroom and as
I come out of the bathroom George
Clooney is like bowing to him right he's
like saying culture Appropriations I've
ever seen one I do that now to him
we bow to each other when I leave we
bought each other so I and he's like
doing that and he's like saying
something to him so I like stop because
I don't want to walk in between them and
I just like I thought it'd be over real
quick but it they kept talking Anonymous
now it looks like I look like an ass
swipe I'm standing there just because
he's George Clooney was anybody else
ever just walked right through so I'm
like you cat you got to walk through now
you can't just stand there you look like
an idiot so as I start to walk through
and then I ducked my head
you know what's crazy if I can add to
that you know George Clooney tells the
exact same story he's like I go to this
place and the only person there's this
guy Jimmy door I bow to him the whole
deal here's a crazy even crazier than
that so about a week ago maybe two I go
uh my wife saved the Boston Legal is on
Hulu now and so that's my all-time
favorite show is Boston Legal I never
liked any of those people in in acting
until they were on that show and I love
them right especially William Shatner
and so I'm sitting there again miss me
and my friend Rick over to having sushi
only people in the place in walks
William Shatner by himself sits down at
the suit so my wife had saved this this
episode and it was about how him and um
his name is Danny Crane on the show and
Alan Shore is uh the other guy I can't
think of his real name but um they're
having they have these conversations at
the end of every episode where they
smoke a cigar and they have a scotch and
they have these heart to hearts and so
they were talking about he said you know
the one guy said my father never
approved of me and he said there's
something there's there's something
there's nothing more horrible than a
father's not approving of his son and
then Denny Crane William Shatner uh says
oh my father always approved to me right
but we know as an audience that his
father disowned him right so then he
finally just snaps and goes my father
disowned me
and Alan Shore looks look at him and
says Denny I'm proud of you and he says
what are you proud of and he says I just
am I always am proud of you oh wow and
my wife saw that and she knew I would
want to see it because it really was
emotional for me and uh I couldn't it
was really a big deal for me and so then
I'm sitting there the next day William
Shatner walks in sits there and I'm just
like what the hell is crazy
and so uh so that was a big deal and we
talked and he told me he got
so he every time he would eat a piece of
fish he would look at me goes this is
amazing and I go yeah this is the best
this is the best fish so how was the
California roll though dude
yeah
he's proud yeah and by the way it's kind
of like and and that's our sponsor today
is the sushi is fine
it can get a better sponsorship than
this so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you
[Music]